usually what you see in a movie was put
there on purpose but not always we've
already covered strange things
accidentally included in the background
of movies such as the unzip texture in
Teen Wolf the head bonking stormtrooper
and Star Wars and a parked car and
Braveheart
all of which and more you can find in
our video 20 movie mistakes you've never
noticed but here are five more
background bloopers you can still catch
on screen think fast
there's an amazing moment in Being John
Malkovich while the scene calling for a
Malkovich to get hit with a can seems to
have been planned the think fast line
apparently wasn't director Spike Jones
said in an audio commentary that a bunch
of extras working on the film such a
case of beer on set and we're getting
pretty lit the director added that the
line the can thrower yelled as the car
zoom past earned him his Screen Actors
Guild card bumping his pay from $100 a
day to seven hundred dollars not a bad
way to run a race hazard pay during key
scene in The Last Samurai Tom Cruise's
character arrives on horseback for the
film's epic final battle as crews
dismounts from his horse the animal can
actually be seen kicking one of the
extras in the groin instead of dropping
to the ground and crying the extras
simply takes a step back reacts silently
and regroups in formation samurai are
known for being disciplined this guy
went the extra mile a random cowboy
nobody watching Pirates of the Caribbean
the curse of the Black Pearl could have
expected what went down on its final
scene after reclaiming the Black Pearl
Captain Jack Sparrow orders his merry
band of pirates to get to work on the
deck just as they begin to move a man
wearing a white t-shirt and a cowboy hat
can be spotted in the background looking
off into distant waters was this
mysterious man's cameo a secret Easter
egg or perhaps a character to be
introduced in the sequels now he was
supposedly just a grip crew member who
forgot to clear the set during filming
fraidy-cat
classic Bond villain Blofeld's white
Persian cat is a pretty creepy customer
and you only looked
the free creature loses a bit of luster
when it legitimately freaks out during
one of the explosion scenes towards the
end of the film
Donald Pleasence who played Blofeld does
his best to keep the cat clutched
tightly to his body but for a few brief
moments the camera captures the frantic
feline scrambling to the nearest
possible exit it's safe to say the cat
was both shaken and stirred dog days
remember the early 90s when pro wrestler
Hulk Hogan attempted a movie career it
didn't work in fact the only reason
anyone talks about his 1993 feature mr.
nanny has nothing to do with the
Hulkster while Hogan tools around on his
motorcycle the camera captures one of
the most bizarre sights in cinema your
eyes aren't playing tricks on you some
random dude threw a dog into the ocean
why who is he did the dog stink or
something was the motorcycle riding
montage so important that this footage
needed to stay in the final cut the only
other question is what makes Hulk Hogan
prouder riding his motorcycle in front
of a dog being thrown in the ocean or
that time he opened pasta restaurant in
the Mall of America for some reason
Monster Mania his get all my
Hulkamaniacs running water and I've
eaten so many Hulk aru's it hooks use I
kind of feel sorry perfect but my
brother thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which crazy
background moments we missed